c'est presque une ville dans la ville
elle est peuplée d'une grande majorité
de jeunes la cité scolaire amiral pierre
bouvet de saint-benoît compte en effet
de lycée un collège et un internat des
centaines et des centaines d'élèves donc
mais leur apprend t-on qui est l amiral
bouvet qui est l amiral bouvet il ya une
dizaine d'années j'avais regardé mais je
me suis le plus à béthanie ce nom et un
navigateur forcément en rapport avec la
marine au bout côté militaire je pense
que c'est un amiral c'était un contre
amiral je ne saurais pas des six tués
quelle date les utiliser votre
intervention nous a incités à y
réfléchir enfants de saint benoît pierre
françois henri etienne bouvet voit le
jour en 1775 comme son papa il sera
marin à 12 ans il effectue sa première
campagne aux indes au côté de son père
en 1792 il est officier de marine mais à
la révolution
ils sont tous deux emprisonnés ils
resteront trois ans en prison
libéré pierre bouvet reprend la mer et
combat les anglais il est plusieurs fois
capturés mais refaire chaque fois de
plus belle en 1804 il se marie à sa
cousine germaine mais continue la guerre
de course contre les anglais dans
l'océan indien sur l'atalante
ils capturent plus de 30 navires
britanniques et leurs riches butin mais
après la victoire de la bataille du
vieux grand-port les ile-de-france et de
bourbon tombe aux mains de l'ennemi en
1800 bouvet et sa famille rentre en
france à bord de l'adel il n'en continue
pas moins son métier d'officier de
marine et sa lutte contre les anglais au
sierra leone notamment son épouse
devenue aveugle et la mort de sa fille
aînée le pousse toutefois à prendre sa
retraite en 1815 il se retire à
saint-servan où il s'engage dans la
politique avec les libéraux
en 1822 officiellement à la retraite il
reçoit le grade de vice amiral
en 1830 il est élu député d'ille et
vilaine un an plus tard il est décoré de
la légion d'honneur et son île natale le
désigne comme représentants aux conseils
des colonies il meurt en 1860